on this thursday night
the first arrests in the assassination
of haiti's president
who's been caught the country's
deepening turmoil
and the new details about the ambush on
jovanelle
breaking news on the assembly of first
nations election for a new national
chief
the candidate who just dropped out fully
vaccinated
and confused i thought you know vaccines
vaccine what happens to immunize
canadians who didn't get canadian
approved shots
and fans banned from the stands it will
feel strange
get ready for the very subdued summer
games
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin in haiti where tonight there is
deepening chaos and confusion
after the assassination of the country's
president
nearly 48 hours after the brazen attack
authorities say they are still hunting
for those who plan the operation
but they say they are making progress
tracking down the gunman involved
they say multiple suspects have been
killed six have been arrested including
one man
who was reported to be an american
authorities have provided no evidence
linking the suspects to the
assassination but the prospect of
foreign involvement
has stoked widespread anger mike
armstrong has tonight's top story
on the growing unrest in a country
already steeped
in turmoil
[Music]
cameras captured the moment police
arrested two men thursday they believe
were involved in the assassination
of the haitian president the pair was
apparently caught by people in the
neighborhood
hiding in bushes and turned over to
police after being roughed up
they killed the president this man says
we're going to make them suffer
according to local media there are now
six men detained
and seven other suspects have been
killed in shootouts with police
at least one of them according to
reports would be an american
a man who at one point commanded the
team of bodyguards
at the canadian embassy in haiti
now new details are coming out about the
attack at the president's home these are
images posted by a haitian media outlet
jovanelle moyes was shot 12 times
murdered in his bedroom
his wife was also shot several times
she's been airlifted to a hospital in
florida
the couple's daughter was hiding in a
bedroom of the home
two servants had been tied up we need to
understand what happened
haiti's ambassador to canada says
investigators now believe
some police officers were involved in
the attack
the home is in a residential
neighborhood with multiple security
checkpoints
and police officers who are supposed to
be acting as guards
the fact that the president and his wife
were practically the only person killed
that means the the the someone opened
the door for them
now haiti is already a country
struggling economically socially and
politically
but the president's death leaves a
gaping power vacuum
the man who should have replaced him
under the constitution the country's
chief
justice died of covid 19 just last month
between poverty and the coronavirus it
is a humanitarian crisis
that will worsen even further without
leadership
the first order of business is to
resolve
not so much the question of the
assassination
but the question of power the next few
days will be
important for haiti aid groups are
already struggling to get
help into the country a power struggle
could make a
desperate situation even worse
mike armstrong global news montreal
breaking news tonight from the assembly
of first nations
a new national chief has just been
elected the vote began yesterday to name
a successor for perry bell guard who
stepped down after seven years
and the race was down to two candidates
former ontario regional chief roseanne
archibald
from taqwa tag moon nation and reginald
belarus
the long time chief of the muskogen
first nation
just a short time ago one of them
dropped out our michael couture joins us
now mike tell us what happened
far roseanne archibald is the new afn
national chief after reginald bell rose
conceded and dropped out of the race
thursday evening now archibald becomes
the first woman to lead the assembly of
first nations
and she called it it she called it her
story
in a week where mary simon was appointed
as the first indigenous governor general
voices are being heard
that were never heard before and we will
not be silenced
goodness and love will prevail
goodness and love were planks of her
campaign and indigenous advocates say
archibald
will do things differently a lot of the
other candidates
i would say in summary talked about
fighting for jurisdiction and fighting
for rights
and which is also very important but
this is a
a little bit of a you know a different
take in
in starting with the love and heart
matters first
archibald's election ushers in a new era
for the afn and it ends a vote
that spanned over two days the field of
seven candidates narrowed after one
round and was poised to go much longer
until a surprise decision by nishnabi
ascii nation grand chief alvin fiddler
who dropped out just before the third
round wrapped up
i support my friend roseanne archibald
to be the next national chief
that support made it a much tighter race
the new national chief will have little
time to celebrate
the country is at a critical juncture on
the road to reconciliation
with the discovery of hundreds of
unmarked graves
of residential school children
some believe canadians are awakening to
the reality in indigenous communities
and feel that can be turned into an
opportunity
we need to create a momentum from here
and start creating
real lasting changes that will also
could end up being becoming part of
new constitutional talks but who will
those talks be with well speculation
continues to swirl that canadians will
be heading to the polls by the fall
meaning new national chief archibald
could be dealing
with a new federal government farah
michael couture in ottawa thank you mike
the new democrats are calling on the
federal justice minister to appoint a
special prosecutor to investigate crimes
against indigenous peoples
at former residential schools nunavut mp
momolac kaccak says offenders need to be
brought to justice
enough is enough indigenous people need
truth
and justice we need full and independent
investigation
that has the power to shine a light on
every faucet
of this national crime and that has
power to bring perpetrators to justice
the justice minister's office responded
in a statement saying
he does not have the authority to
initiate criminal investigations but
we'll consider all options that will
allow survivors their communities and
the country
to move forward on the path to healing
and reconciliation
canada's first indigenous justice
minister jody wilson-raybould says she
will not run in the next
federal election the independent mp for
vancouver granville says she decided
not to put her name forward for
reelection in part because she
is dismayed by the state of canadian
politics
in a letter posted online she says it
has become more and more toxic
and ineffective while simultaneously
marginalizing individuals
from certain backgrounds federal
politics is in my view
increasingly a disgraceful triumph of
harmful partisanship
over substantive action wilson raybould
won her seat in 2019 as an independent
after being kicked out of the liberal
party during the snc level and affair
more pain for the leader of the green
party two staffers were reportedly cut
from enemy paul's office
at a time when other federal parties are
ramping up their representation ahead of
a
widely expected election call now it all
comes after the party's rising star
jennica atwin
crossed the floor joining the liberals
ross lord reports on the green party's
internal turmoil as federal parties ramp
up public appearances to get their
messages to canadians now is not the
time to attract attention for all the
wrong reasons
that's what's happening to the greens
the only party whose leader enemy paul
is not already an elected member of
parliament a string of internal
controversies
including the defection of star mp
jennica atwin over the party's position
on israel
threatens to stain the once ascendant
green brand
well i'm worried about that you know we
have so much
momentum green the green movement has so
much momentum
around the world there's been momentum
in canada too
on prince edward island the green party
came out of nowhere to become the
official opposition two years ago
gains in federal politics have been
smaller but as
fighting climate change becomes a bigger
priority for voters
analysts say this should be a time for
green glory
instead they say the party is unraveling
if the party does not stand behind the
leader how can the party in good
conscience
ask for your vote if they don't have
their internal house in order
and so i think these sorts of questions
have to be resolved immediately
i think she's honestly potentially past
the point where this can be resolved
others suggest patience is required with
any new leader
i totally give her
the support to make mistakes and to
learn
with the number of paid party staffers
reportedly being cut in half
paul may now be without keys support
personnel when it matters most
she's blamed internal feuding on a small
group of rogue counselors
suggesting she's being attacked in part
because she's a black woman
her office declined global news request
for an interview
the party executive is set to hold a
confidence vote later this month on
paul's leadership
ross lord global news
big news tonight for parents in british
columbia the federal government and the
province have reached a deal
on funding child care as part of the
agreement in the next five years
we'll work with the provincial
government to achieve an average of
10 dollar a day child care for all
regulated spaces for kids under
six trudeau says the agreement will also
create
thirty thousand new spaces for children
under six before twenty twenty seven
bc is the first province to accept the
federal offer of subsidized child care
cp rail is pledging one million dollars
to support wildfire recovery efforts in
linton bc
global news captured these images from
outside the exclusion zone you can see
the houses that are
reduced to rubble the fire on june 30th
destroyed
most of the village two people died and
several others
are still unaccounted for the prime
minister met with the premier of the
province and the mayor of clinton today
to check in on the recovery efforts on
friday a bus will take residents on a
tour of their community
the cause of the fire isn't yet known
but there is speculation it was sparked
by the breaking of a passing train one
province is planned for
vaccination passports coming up what
this means for those who are
unvaccinated plus
what happens when you get immunized with
shots that are not approved in canada
pfizer says it will ask the united
states for emergency authorization next
month for a
third booster dose of its covid19
vaccine
pfizer says early data shows that
another shot within 12 months
could dramatically boost immunity and
potentially help better protect against
the delta variant
delta is now the dominant strain in the
united states
the drug maker is also talking with
regulators in
other countries plans are underway in
quebec to roll out covid19
vaccine passports the province says the
digital passport system could be
implemented by september
after everyone is given the chance to
get both doses
if there's a spike in covid19 cases
quebec could use the passports to
exclude unvaccinated people from some
non-essential services like
gyms or bars the province says the
system could help prevent
another lockdown as of tonight across
canada
44 percent of people 12 and older are
fully vaccinated 78 percent have had at
least one dose
and while that is progress there are
signs canada's vaccine
uptake is beginning to plateau
we should not assume we have crossed the
finish line while canadians are steadily
coming forward for second doses
the rate of increase for first doses has
slowed
dr theresa tam is urging everyone
eligible to get their shots to help
canada get ahead
of highly transmissible variants before
the fall
and for some vaccinated canadians abroad
there's a new problem that's emerging as
they look to travel home
those who got vaccines that were not
approved by health canada
are not eligible to skip quarantine as
jamie morocco reports
that's led to frustration and confusion
though shinnon lee is fully vaccinated
against covet 19
she isn't able to bypass the two-week
travel quarantine
my best shot to get any vaccine was to
you know take the chance
and do it in china so i didn't really
consider i thought you know vaccines
vaccine
because the 30 year-old received the
cinevac and cinefarm vaccines while
overseas which are not yet approved by
health canada
new federal travel guidelines don't
apply to her if every country does this
we're going to have chaos only four drug
makers coveted 19 shots are approved for
use in canada
pfizer biontech moderna astrazeneca and
johnson and johnson
bioethicist carrie bowman says covet
shots should be regulated
internationally
i feel the only solution is is to look
to the vaccines that the world health
organization has approved
but not all experts consider it that
simple when canada authorizes a vaccine
for use within canada it's conducted a
very
sophisticated meticulous evaluation of
all the scientific data
supporting the vaccine as well as
evaluation and some cases on-site
inspection
of the manufacturing facilities for
those who can't wait for wider canadian
approvals
revaccination may be a short-term
solution i don't see medically that
there would be a reason
they'd be concerned about that lee who
travels for work is considering a whole
other double dose
hopefully i won't have to deal with this
much longer well experts note that
mixing vaccines has provided a powerful
immune response for many in preliminary
studies
there's currently no data on combining
three
or even four different shots pharah
jamie morocco in toronto thank you jamie
still ahead the hurdles one woman faced
when she brought her husband
home from long-term care
when the pandemic hit the decision to
remove a loved one from long-term care
and bring them home
was a complicated and painstaking one
for many canadians families struggled to
balance concerns about isolation with
the risks of covet 19.
for one ontario woman the decision was
clear
barbara heumann chose to take her
husband out but what she soon learned
was that the process
was easier said than done mike drollet
reports
this was always the plan retire in the
relative tranquility of rural ontario
but life is rarely that simple and after
frank carlucci suffered a traumatic
brain injury
he needed more care than his wife
barbara heumann could provide
and he ended up in a long-term care home
i honestly thought this is where he's
going to be for the rest of his life
everything changed with the pandemic for
two weeks she would visit and sit
outside his window
his isolation she felt was too great and
with the progress he had made in physio
she decided to bring him home you don't
want people to discover
issues like this um after they've
actually
left the home you want them to you know
go with you know eyes wide open
the biggest hurdle barbara was told was
if frank's health deteriorated
and he needed to return a lot of those
people are getting told the same thing
as me if you take them out you lose your
bed
she offered to continue paying for the
bed but was told she couldn't
of even greater concern frank's doctor
told barbara he could only treat her
husband
if he was in the home i called him i
begged his office
begged them she had no choice but to
accept the doctor's decision
but remain steadfast with hers it was
made easier by the fact that ontario
like several other provinces
determined residents who leave long-term
care homes can return to them
without going to the end of new wait
lists but there's a catch
the policy ends whenever the pandemic
does if ontario basically says as of
september 1st you know
we are now you know the pandemic is now
over as far
as far we're concerned you know then you
know after that period
then you know you're not protected under
these changes
ontario's ministry of long-term care
told global news in a statement
residents who choose to leave homes not
in outbreak
are discharged it's not what barbara
hoped to hear but
at least it's definitive much like her
resolve
it was a little bit scary but i knew it
would work out i just
had to be positive and do what i
i had to do what was best for him it's
her way of promising him true care
for the long term mike durley global
news toronto
competing without crowds next what an
olympics under a state of emergency
means for athletes
fans won't be a problem at the tokyo
olympics all spectators have been
banned as japan prepares for a fourth
state of emergency in the capital due to
covet 19.
now these games will be different from
any ever held before
and many wonder why they're still even
going ahead
crystal command seeing looks at how our
canadian athletes
are feeling
a warm welcome for british athletes
arriving in tokyo but their olympic
experience
will be like no other
[Music]
spectators will now be banned under new
emergency restrictions
as covet 19 infections here have reached
a two-month high
we'll support any measure
which is necessary to have safe
and secure olympic and paralympic
games until now officials were
unwavering in their position that the
games would be a display of triumph over
the pandemic
but some experts say all of the changes
to the games
may affect athletes for most top
performers it will feel strange and it
may actually make them a bit concerned
that they may not
deliver their best performances
fans cladding flags packed venues and
screaming spectators are a part of the
olympic experience
swimmer penny alexia had a
record-setting olympic debut in rio
she knows tokyo will be very different
i am sure we're just going to stay in a
little bubble it's not going to be
anything too too exciting but
just to go is really really fun the
chance to compete
is also key for sprinter crystal emanuel
for me i just stay focused on the goals
at hand and you know
put it to my team to to get us there
safe and back the canadian olympic
committee
is consulting regularly with public
health
i think everyone is going in as they say
with their eyes wide open recognizing uh
the risks involved and certainly uh the
epidemiologic situation in the general
population what's happening generally in
japan
obviously i think is very concerning for
the authorities there the state of
emergency in tokyo
is set to remain in place throughout the
games until august 22nd
it could be extended to cover the
paralympics as well
all a part of an experience unlike
anything
the world has seen before crystal gamson
global news
london the past year and a half have
been
unlike anything we've ever seen before
that is global national for this
thursday i'm farren oster thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us
take a look at tonight's york canada it
is this rainbow over
last mountain lake in saskatchewan until
tomorrow
take care of yourselves and each other
[Music]
you